girl what did you guys talk about oh
look at that wow okay wow there's a lot
of love Embrace there A lot of times
love Dale did you whisper come on come
on
I mean it's so funny because what are
the chances that he's standing there all
alone when I walked in and I haven't
seen him in a long time yeah and I said
I'm so glad to see you and you know he
gave me and that was a genuine hug too
no that looked like a dinner it was a
genuine hug he goes no Gail look at me
I'm really really glad to see you ah and
then you know what he said to me he said
How's Kirby doing now he hasn't said uh
that's what he said How's Kirby doing I
said can I show you my grandmother
picture he goes please I'd love to see
it I go really you'd love to see it goes
yes I took it out showed it to him he
hasn't seen or talked to Kirby in over
15 years it's not like he knew I was
coming but that really is like that yes
it literally is what he does yeah I am
nuts about him I've known him a long
time and I just think he is terrific